it's new this morning pfizer says its  covet 19 vaccine  is safe for children as young as 12  years old the drug maker studied the  effects of its vaccine on volunteers in  the u.s between 12 and 15.  preliminary data showed no cases of  covet among those fully vaccinated  so pfizer says this medicine is safe and  strongly will protect  young teenagers there's 12-year-old  caleb chung he was one of the trial  participants  it was definitely a very special  opportunity  to be able to do something like this  because usually  i'm just at home doing online school and  there's not much i can really do  to fight back against the virus brave  little kid there  the study will continue to track those  participants for two more  years in order to gather information  about long-term protection  in a few weeks pfizer plans to ask the  fda to allow the emergency use of those  shots  in children starting at the age of 12.  it is currently authorized for those  16 and older